a lost soul.
Arch, I'm an angel. My name is Gabriel.
I'm here to save you.
What? So, Kiana Reeves is back in the
limelight. He is uh acting in a new
movie that has over two million views in
just a couple of days. It's called Good
Fortune. Anybody heard of it? No. No.
Come out already? No. No. the trailer
just dropped and it just like I I think
it's because it's Kiana Reeves, you
know, like he's from the Matrix and
hasn't really done anything in a while.
It seems like it's been been kind of
quiet. Uh it's a comedy. I Let's take a
look at it because uh it's quite
interesting.
Martha, yes, Gabriel. Is there any way I
can have more meaningful duties? I want
to guide people. I want to change their
lives. To save a lost soul, you have to
find a lost soul. Hey, Arch, don't
forget your pea bottle, bro.
A lost soul.
Arch, I'm an angel. My name is Gabriel.
I'm here to save you.
What? Who the are you? How do you know
my name? I'm normally only in charge of
saving people from texting and driving.
Wait, you're telling me I have a budget
guardian angel? Kind of.
Do you know that guy? He's got the long
hair, kind of tall.
Yeah, Gabriel. He's an angel. Hot. Like,
does this strike to you as something
that displays the biblical story
correctly? No, I think humor always
thrives off of of of either putting
somebody down or, you know, making fun
of somebody or whatever like that. So,
um it's it's it's going to probably poke
fun at the Christianity ideas and I'm
I'm I mean I'm I'm assuming, you know,
that they're going to just show this
ridiculousness and then probably in the
end they're going to be like, well, we
just accept everybody and you know, so
very unbiblical ideas, I'm sure. And
Seth Rogan's name was on the credits for
that. And he doesn't take it light when
it comes to, you know, mocking
Christianity as well, which is no
surprise. I mean, they they've been
doing it more than than ever. Mhm. Case,
you kind of looked into this. Yeah. I'm
I looked at it a little bit. I didn't
look very deeply. I just It's sad when
it's portrayed that that God is the one
who he doesn't know who the lost souls
are. True. Good point. The angel Gabriel
has to go figure it out on his own and
and find one. Even the angels are
completely ignorant. Mhm. And so God, by
implication, more ignorant, doesn't know
who the lost souls are. You just got to
find them, you know, like it's some
random game. And uh and then of course
the scenario that's
that's that's put out there is, you
know, well, he's he's a lost soul cuz he
hasn't found
his financial fulfillment. We'll look at
that in just a second to kind of explain
that storyline a little bit more, but
basically it's about Gabriel on the
right and uh this guy named Arge on the
left. And so he he is uh having this
terrible life. Um I mean at least
according to him, he's just not making
it to the top. He's kind of seen as a
dorky kind of guy. And uh he's at a
Denny's and just it's just a complete
mess. And that's where Gabriel meets him
and he's like a lost soul. Oh, I can
help him because Gabriel wants more
responsibility. He wants more to do with
his life and his position. But it's
interesting. I feel like Gabriel in this
sense looks kind of stupid. Like he
looks like a dumb being who's just like
kind of a dork himself almost, you know?
And the idea that that if he's trying to
save somebody and that he's on God's
side, the fact that he's unsatisfied
with the work that he's doing that he
now needs to go, you know, somewhere
deeper, find fulfillment because what
he's doing isn't fulfilling him or
whatever is a total slam on God. It
almost sounds like a flashback to when
Satan actually before he was cast out of
heaven and and and all that. The reason
why that happened is because he um
wanted more than whatever his position
was, hell. and and um we understand that
Satan who was Lucifer at the time which
means lightbearer was one of the angels
the covering cherubs right that was like
overseeing or protecting the the ark of
the covenant which is the where the ten
commandments are kept this is a very
long in-depth study that you really have
to go through the Bible to understand
and to look into um but but yeah he had
a high position high position and he's
like that's not enough you see this kind
of a similar vibe over here in this
movie. But uh so the movie hasn't been
released yet. It's just a trailer.
There's actually very little information
about it. But there is something called
Cineacon where basically these big
studios will come and play some clips
for reporters who are you know reporting
for the movie industry who then can kind
of you know give feedback or promote it
or talk about advance to and then the
studios can see okay is this is this
something that people would appreciate
or not. So, Hollywood Reporter was there
and they kind of talk about the footage
that was shown them at the uh Cineacon
and it says it starts with a shot of
Reeves standing on a dome overlooking a
sprawling city. His angel's wings are
visible on his back and a voice over
finds the star explaining his role as a
guide who wants to help people in their
lives. The next shot is of Ansari's
character. Ansar is also a director of
this movie and a Denny's diner booth as
he's reprimanded by a male staff member.
And then it says that it's revealed that
Ansari plays a man who is down his luck
and struggling to make ends meet. He
takes gig work as a task rabbit of
sorts. And uh it's interesting where it
says so this is where Seth Rogan comes
in. He plays this wealthy like corporate
kind of guy. And so he's like cleaning
his pool and and and taking care of his
cars and all that kind of stuff. But uh
what's going on over there with Seth
Rogan's character Jeff? He's full on
like doing drugs and all those kind of
things um here at the bottom sea from
fixing his pool to finding him a shaman
for an iawasa journey. So we can see
that what kind of uh elements are being
portrayed in this movie, right? And and
what's wild is that we had uh this lady
on our show once, blessings, she went on
an Iawaska trip when I flew overseas to
take Iawaska and that's where she
started seeing demons, fullon demons.
And she said that there was another girl
when they asked her the shamans like
what what what are your expectations for
this Awaska trip? And she's like, I just
want to have a cosmic orgy basically.
Yeah. Sex with demons. And she saw that
girl later on full on like out of her
mind possessed. Wow. And so like this is
a movie about this guardian angel
Gabriel and then include this in there
and if you really understand what
happens when you take Iawaska. In fact I
know of an individual who um used to
take DMT which is like the the basis or
the root ingredient for Iawaska. And so
he said when he took
DMT, he says every single time when you
take any drug, you have a different
experience. But with DMT, everybody sees
the same thing. You have different
brains, but you see the same thing. And
it's always this dark entity that says
come and like give in and surrender
yourself and and it's very tempting to
give in. So it's all demonic demonic
man. So this is part of that movie. So
this guy Arge, he uh is like it says
down on his luck. And so Gabriel's like,
"You know what? I'm going to show you
that your life you're living right now,
the modest life, is so much better than
this rich life you want from your boss,
Jeff. I'm going to swap you guys." And
so Gabriel makes them swap and he's
like, "Arge, how how's it going?" And
Arch is like, "Well, I'm loving it. I
have money. I have fame. I have women."
And it's like, "That's not what was
supposed to happen." And so as a result
of that it says failing to convince his
Gabriel's human to appreciate life reefs
Gabriel loses his wings making him human
down on his luck the actual angel
Gabriel ends up becoming roommates with
Rogan's character Jeff who is now in the
body of Ansari's character. So kind of
weird how, you know, there's this
angelic being, this beautiful being that
God created that shows up many times in
the Bible and now all of a sudden he's
like stuck on Earth.
Hey,
subscribe. If you want to learn Spanish,
a great way will be watching our videos
for practice.
Yeah. Well, you know, in the Bible, God
is promising that um you know, if we
surrender our lives to him, right, that
that that eventually obviously there'll
be this beautiful life that that you're
going to live. And if you, you know,
live with the pleasures of this world
for a season, you know, it's going to be
like this. And so, this is kind of like
making it like, well, everything they
said that this life would be like a bad
life is is is is not as bad as over here
is boring, you know? So I think by
default people look at that and be like
well yeah you're going to want to do
whatever you want to do here and just
glorifies that sinful direction the the
simple modest life you know where you're
not desirable. Well in the movie it's
shown as not desirable but but in
reality that's what God wants for us. In
fact, Jesus was a humble carpenter,
right? And it's often spoken enough that
that he could have ended up anywhere in
in um society on a societal ladder. And
a lot of the Pharisees and Sadducees
were looking for a Messiah that was that
high up like super highly educated,
which Jesus was not. He was studied from
the Bible, not from the schools. Super
rich and just like wants to do away with
the Romans. But in fact, he came as a as
a humble carpenter. Yeah. With who was
poor. It wasn't the hero they were
looking for. Exactly. So, this is a
complete misrepresentation of what God
really wants from us. And then to then
say like, oh yeah, they just took his
wings from him and he became a human and
he just has to like live this life
basically in a sinful world even though
angels are God's perfect creation and
they haven't sinned is very strange to
me. Makes God out to be this tyrant.
Yeah, absolutely. and it makes a god out
to be someone who doesn't fulfill. Um,
so the director also says, "Movies allow
us to live life in someone else's shoes.
If you can write about things that
everyone is dealing with that no one is
talking about, you're in a good area."
He said, "This movie is about what a lot
of people are doing, struggling." So
yeah, I understand that it relates to,
you know, you as as a normal human being
as well who is struggling, but again,
what seeds are they planting in your
mind? I think that God doesn't have
answers. Yeah. Mhm. But I think this is
also a pretty tailtale for people that
go like, "Oh, it's just entertainment.
You guys are looking into this too long
or too too deeply, right?" Well, look,
the the director himself is admitting
that you put yourself in that that
person's position. So, by default, you
watching this, you're vicariously living
through these characters. You're kind of
going on the journey that this movie is
taking you on. There was also a director
uh the the name has slipped from my
memory for just a second. Maybe you guys
can help me here. But uh he was saying
that that Yeah. Like you just uh there
every good good director does this like
you slap them with your view of
morality, your view of the world. You
know what I'm talking about? Yeah. There
you go. And and so this is commonly
done. I mean it's absolutely you think
about it. The power you have through
media, the power you have through
cinema. It's it's a propaganda machine
for good or evil. If you're getting your
morals from Hollywood and not the Bible,
uh, that's that's challenging. Yeah.
Okay. So, last one here. So, uh, Aziz
Ansari, he is the director here and and
and plays Arj in the movie. He says he
cast Kiana Reeves as an angel named
Gabriel in his new Lionsgate film, Good
Fortune. But it says God apparently
wasn't looking out for Ree when he
tripped on the rug in his trailer. So,
Kiana Ree, he he was on the set. He was
in his trailer. He tripped on a rug and
he broke his leg on set. And so you can
see the mindset of the people who create
this movie, right? The Hollywood
Reporter is like, "Haha, you know, God
wasn't looking out for Kiana Ree when he
tripped on his trailer and and broke his
leg." You know that sarcasm that's
surrounding this, which really is also
found a lot in comedy movies. Sarcasm
toward religion and just making fun of
it. And also playing on the concept of
break a leg, you know. Well, yeah, this
is true. Yeah. But yeah, I I think you
can kind of see the mindset of Hollywood
here that Hollywood is not for God. No,
it is not. All you got to watch is one
minute of Diddy Trial. Diddy's trial.
This is true. Pretty much will sum up
what that place is behind doors. Yeah.
So, yeah. So, hey, you know, if we're
involved um watching these kind of
movies, um Scotty, what would you say to
someone like that? And having been an
actor yourself? I I I think that if you
really want to live your life according
to what the Bible is is is saying, I I
always say just go back to God and be
like, God, is there something here that
you want to change in my life? I was a
big movie fan, loved movies. If you
really gave me the choice, probably 100%
of the time, I would have made that
choice to watch those things. But I I
prayed a simple prayer. Lord, if there's
things that you don't want me to watch,
then you have permission to change my
heart. And today, I don't watch any of
this junk and don't care. And so, that
wasn't because I did that. That was
literally giving God the permission to
change your taste buds for those things.
Yeah. So, um, yeah, don't watch this
stuff. It's if especially if you're a
Christian, it's conflicting to what the
Bible's trying to teach you. Keith, you
grew up Christian and, uh, you left the
church, but you never left the church.
What are your thoughts? You used to be a
pretty avid movie watcher, too. Yeah, my
family actually did leave the church
when I was young. And Oh, I see. Okay.
Uh that's when all the media definitely
came in and became a big uh influence in
our life. And it's weird. You'll you'll
watch stuff and I remember watching The
Matrix and thinking this has some
similarities to the Bible, but I wasn't
reading my Bible. and you you
recognize maybe some parts of the
storyline, but you're not always looking
at it from God's perspective. Especially
if you're not reading the Bible, you're
not going to see it from God's
perspective. It's like I tell people, if
you want to if you want the
right guidance in your life, you have to
get it from the right source. Mhm. And
this isn't the right source. And people
are like, "Well, you know, it's it's
funny, but but is it is it funny?" You
know, and then, you know, as a
Christian, if you're finding this funny,
why would you go and turn around to God
and and pray to him when you have a
problem because he's just, you know,
you're just making it look like God
can't do anything and doesn't care. I'm
not surprised that they are once again
mocking God. But I am not insensitive to
it just because it is common. You know,
as much as it hurts, I know it hurts
more to God, he feels it more because,
you know, he sent his son here to go
through through so much. You can see
even on on the book that we've talked a
few times about um the case for Christ.
They also explained there the the
medical aspect of what Jesus had to go
through. But the medical wasn't even the
biggest part was more of the emotional
Jesus, you know, going through all of
this for us and he did all of this for
us and then we just, you know, kind of
like mock him or jokingly do movies or
watch the movies. There's no difference
between uh being entertained by the
movie and actually participating in the
movie. To God is the same thing. Mockery
is mockery. Sin is sin, right? So at the
same time that I'm not surprised, it is
still really, you know, is is really sad
and I know God feels it the most. I
think if you were to um really try to
understand like what this really means,
let's just say you're married, right?
and somebody was making fun of your wife
and slamming her and jokes about her and
calling her a prostitute and whatever,
right? How would that make you feel?
Yeah. And everybody's laughing about it
and stuff like this. Would you watch
that movie if it was about somebody that
you love? Now, let me bring it one step
further. What if it was you? What if
people were making fun of you? How would
you feel? What would that do to you? If
the person you saved somebody's life,
let's say, yeah, you did something kind
and that person just talks trash about
you. when you feel offended, right? But
then on top of that, they pay to go see
this mockery of you. You saved their
life. They pay to see the mockery of
you. They just got themselves some
popcorn and chewing some popcorn and
some some Kit Kats and just like
whatever, you know, that'd be hurtful.
Yeah. Put yourselves in in in God's
shoes. Yeah. And and think that through
like that and be like, if this is
something that you could honestly say,
"Oh, I welcome it. make fun of me and
you know totally distort what I'm all
about and everything like this. Nobody
wants that. And so why are we doing that
to God? I believe God does have a sense
of humor because he wants us to be
happy, joyful, all that. But we all, you
know, there are limits. You know, there
are types of humor. Yeah. He has a
tasteful, sinless sense of humor that
doesn't make fun of anybody else or
doesn't glorify sin. So yeah, we need to
um you know keep our keep our thoughts,
our minds on Jesus because he wants to
have that relationship with us and and
you know he did die for us. And I really
appreciate what you guys brought out
about the idea of if if this was you or
your wife or your other loved one. And I
think I hope that people will really
considered us and that and really search
their hearts like what what place does
Jesus have in my life? you know, if I if
I would go and pay or not even pay, but
just go see these kind of things and
have no problems with
it. But what if it's your spouse? Then
what does it say about your relationship
with God? And no, God is a loving God.
He's a forgiving God. He is a merciful
God. And he's not sitting there like,
"Ah, you messed up. I'm going to zap
you." He says, "Come unto me all you are
heavy laden, and I will give you rest."
He wants to give us his peace, his
forgiveness, for if we confess our sins,
he's faithful and just to forgive us our
sins and cleanse us from all
unrighteousness. That's his goal. So if
anybody has sees this and is like, I'm
not in the right place with God. I've
done those things. We all have. We all
at this table have. And God forgives us
all. He forgives us all. And he wants to
forgive everybody else, too, if we ask
him. If you like this video, like,
subscribe, and hit the notification bell
so you know when we launch new videos.
and drop a comments below and we'll try
to get back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.